[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka james pun and in this
video we're breaking down the two
post-credits scenes that come with the
suicide squad they leave a couple of
hints for the future and throughout
we'll be discussing the ending what
could be happening next time and why
john cena is going to be the biggest
peacemaker in the dc universe full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't had a
chance to check out the movie then i
highly recommend that you check out now
thumbs up the video if you're not martin
scorsese and make sure you subscribe to
stick around at longer than black god
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the breakdown
okay so the suicide squad follows task
force x as they're sent to the quarter
maltese in order to destroy a tower
named jottenheim in the opening of the
movie the members of the team are split
into two groups with one side being
absolutely demolished by the quarter
maltesian military savant captain
boomerang black god tdk javelin and
mongol are all killed leaving just
harley rick flag and weasel as the only
survivors we don't learn the latter is
alive until the first post credits scene
which i'll talk about later on as i
think this will tie into peacemaker in
some way this leaves the b team a
bloodsport rat catcher polka dot man
king shark and peacemaker to reunite
with holly and flagg i think there was
was someone else with them but i can't
can't quite remember who but either way
they captured the thinker who heads up
jonheim and slowly they start to learn
the truth about what's really going on
throughout the film we discover that
this house is the gigantic alien star or
the conqueror who has the capability to
create a hive mind turns out that the us
government helped to fund human
experimentation which involved sending
people from the island's populace
straight to starro due to a military
coup and new leader of the island the us
now worry that things might come to
light upon discovering this rick flag
decides that the public need to know but
just before he can expose the operation
he's killed by peacemaker who stabs him
through the heart ratcatcher takes the
data and peacemaker then chases her down
however just before he can kill her
bloodsport arrives and puts a bullet in
his throat now the rest of the group
gone to kill sorrow and they set up
contingency plans that will release the
info if walla decides to kill them
however it's not over yet and the
post-credits scene reveals that
peacemaker is alive and well in the
hospital man got his third leg sorry his
his leg in a cast and he's on the road
to recovery but it's clear that he will
be going on other missions for walla and
her underlings in the future these
include john economos and emilia
harcourt who both pulled from the comics
john worked directly with task force x
from time to time and harcourt was an
argus member that was often sent in to
keep them in line we know both are set
to feature in the peacemaker show and
it's likely that they'll have big roles
during the movie waller attempted to
wipe out the entire squad because they
refused to leave starro to destroy the
quarter maltese however her staff ended
up knocking her out and because of this
they're all getting punished and put
onto other assignments therefore i think
other members of the operation will show
up too however this pair will be the
main ones running the show i think that
once he recovers they will very much be
his handlers and in the episodes they'll
appoint him jobs that involve saving the
[ __ ] world there's a whole host of dc
villains that the character could end up
going up against and after we had polka
dot man i'd love to see some more of the
goofier ones pulled into the overall
universe like condiment king and kite
man tom king actually did an incredible
story with kite man that i think would
work really well in live action this
told of the character getting revenge
after the death of his son in the war of
jokes and riddles and he's got a very
tragic backstory i think this would work
really really well and this show could
handle several goofy characters that
might not have previously been brought
to the screen i think one big issue with
the show is that it's tied to the main
dc universe so it'll be difficult to
have him straight too far off the course
of whatever warner bros end up deciding
to do with these movies therefore the
direction they take things will probably
be a jokey one that involves more
obscure characters such as weasel now
speaking of weasel we know he's alive
after the showdown on the beach weasel
is actually portrayed by sean gunn aka
james gunn's brother over the years
james has had him appear in a lot of his
films including guardians of the galaxy
in which he showed up as crackling he
also did the mocap for rocket a lot of
the time and appeared as calendar man in
the film so it's clear gunn likes using
his brother as much as possible
in very very stupid roles now because of
james heading up the peacemaker series i
can see his brother being brought back
as weasel as they could have easily left
the character dead if they had no
further plans for him he'll probably
still be a joke but he's not the only
person that i think will pop up in the
show i actually think that bloodsport
aka idris elba will be in the season at
some point too though elba has been in a
lot of films he's also been a key
character in several tv shows such as
the wire the office and also luther i
would love to see him pop up at some
point as peacemaker will likely be
wanting revenge for him shooting his
load down his throat
cut that bit cut that bit out i didn't
mean it like that
cut that out this will of course cause
some tension in the show as the us won't
want him dead due to the contingency
plans thus peacemaker will have to
wrestle with whether to put his country
before his personal vendetta and this is
something that he tackled with in the
main movie there's so many potential
directions that they can take things and
you can really see the character sort of
going back and forth between doing the
right thing for his country and doing
the right thing for him now one thing
that the characters share and might even
be able to find common ground over is
their relationships with their fathers
we do know that in the hbo max show
robert patrick will be playing
peacemaker's dad due to patrick's age i
think that means he will at least be
alive in present day as if they were
only showing peacemakers pops and
flashbacks then they would likely go
with a younger actor therefore the two
will probably share some screen time
together and we could end up discovering
why peacemaker is the way that he is
peacemaker is pretty much captain
america pushed to the extreme and he
puts patriotism above everything else
this includes his friends and thus we
can explore why he's taken on this
mentality of blind loyalty when he's
seen firsthand that there are aspects of
it which are flawed i don't think
they'll get too political as gun tends
to keep things in the subtext rather
than hitting you over the head with what
he believes however we could explore
what happens when you tie your identity
to a black and white ideology that
leaves no room for compromise and means
you would basically eat a beachful of
dicks now that kind of mentality extends
beyond patriotism and of course can be
applied to a number of things peacemaker
very much strikes me as a character who
sees the world as being one way and
he'll stamp down anyone who doesn't
believe the same thing that means
metaphorically his character arc could
be used for a simile for a number of
things that we see in modern day this
will no doubt tie back to his dad and
there's so many different avenues they
can do with their relationship now
lastly we know the character vigilante
will be featuring in the show and adrian
chase is a da who helps to fight crime
he's the second version of the character
and will provide a great opposite or
ally to peacemaker i can actually see
the pair facing off against one another
as he's more of a good guy than a bad
one whereas peacemaker is someone who
thinks he's a good guy but he's actually
more of a villain the pair have crossed
paths several times and chase even
retired at one point only to take the
mantle back up because peacemaker
murdered dave winston who had taken over
the role peacemaker actually did this in
front of chase and thus i can see this
arc possibly being adapted for the show
he's said to be played by freddie
stromer who you might know from the
harry potter films and yeah there's a
lot that they can do with it anyway
that's pretty much the way i think it'll
be happening and obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts on the future of the
franchise as well as the film we're
currently running a competition right
now and giving away three mc box sets on
the 30th of august and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the movie we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now say that's
you then message me on twitter heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
full breakdown of the film which will be
linked on screen right now we've gone
over the full plot and also some of the
easter eggs in it so it's definitely
worth checking out right after this if
not then thank you for singing through
the video i've been paul i'll see you
next time take care peace